la colère des policiers qui dénoncent un
coup de pression selon le syndicat unité
sgp police fo près de la moitié des
policiers chargés de sécuriser les
manifestations à paris sont en arrêt
maladie pour burnout certains d'entre
convoqué selon le syndicat par le
médecin du travail à la demande de la
préfecture de police de paris pour
contrôler la validité de leur arrêt
maladie écoutez ces réactions micro un
de charles godrich
la préfecture de police ne veut rien
entendre et continue à convoquer les
collègues les médecins statutaires au
mépris des règles élémentaires du droit
je rappelle que lorsqu'un collègue tombe
malade il est convoqué à la messi
statutaire à la fin de son arrêt maladie
pour voir s'il est apte à reprendre le
service là les collègues semaine arrêt
maladie samedi ils sont bloqués dès le
lundi matin donc au mépris des règles du
droit quelque part c'est une hypocrisie
rambo leur faire avouer que leur arrêt
maladie ne sont que les arrêts de
complaisance pourtant ce sont des
médecins qui ont prêté le serment dicko
d'hippocrate qui ont de décès arrêt
maladie oui ses collègues qui sont en
berne haroun parce que il ya un mal être
au niveau 2
service mama l'aide qu'on dénonce depuis
un an déjà donc le déaut de des opc est
pas censé ignorer que c'est compliqué
parce qu'il ya une suractivité des
cycles horaires compliqués ils sont en
quête d'eux avec des rappels conséquent
sur leur jour de repos des décalages par
moins de 5000 décalage pratiquement sûr
rien sur cette année donc voilà c'est
c'est un ras-le-bol général et puis une
vie privée qui n'existent plus donc
un mal-être quotidien est la seule
réponse du directeur de l'ordre public
de la circulation aujourd'hui c'est de
mettre un coup de pression les
convoquant la médecine statutaire